breaking news jack dorsey stepping down
as twitter ceo yes that is the news this
morning jack dorsey the founder and ceo
of twitter one of the largest social
media companies in the world has decided
to step down effective immediately now
jack dorsey obviously is somebody who
everyone knows he runs twitter he runs
square and he's a big big fan of bitcoin
but jack dorsey has been spending so
much time focused on bitcoin that i have
to think that it probably plays a part
in his decision to go ahead and step
down he will remain on the board of
directors until approximately may or so
and then he will actually leave the
board of directors as well the
replacement for jack dorsey that has
been selected by the board unanimously
is the cto i mean yes the perag agarwal
is going to be the ceo of twitter
effective immediately this is news to a
lot of people that jack dorsey one is
stepping down but two is that it's
happening immediately and the cto is
going to step in as the ceo now if we go
ahead and we look jack posted his
resignation letter on twitter and what
he said was not sure anyone has heard
but i resigned from twitter and here we
have the actual letter itself he said
after almost 16 years of having a role
at our company from co-founder to ceo to
chair to exec chair to interim cd ceo to
ceo man that's a lot i decided it's
finally time for me to leave why there's
a lot of talk about the importance of a
company being found or led he ultimately
believes that's severely limiting in a
single point of failure interesting use
of the word single point of failure he's
worked hard to ensure the company can
break away from its founding and
founders and there's three reasons he
believes now is the right time to leave
first is peraga is becoming the ceo the
board ran a rigorous process and
anonymously appointed him he's been his
choice for some time given how deeply
understands the company and its needs
he's been behind every critical decision
helped turn the company around he's
curious probing rational creative
demanding self-aware and humble great
great qualities and he leads with heart
and soul and is someone i learn from
daily my trust in him as our ceo is bone
deep the second is brett taylor has
agreed to become the board chair brett
joined the board when jack became the
ceo he's been excellent in every way he
said having brett in this leadership
role gives me a lot of confidence in the
strength of our board going forward you
know have no idea how happy this makes
me he then goes on with the resignation
letter and he says that the third thing
is that all of the twitter employees
they have a lot of ambition and
potential on the team consider that the
new ceo started as an engineer who cared
deeply about our work and now he's the
ceo on top of that they all have the
potential to change the course of the
company for the better and jack believes
that with his heart now peraga is the
ceo starting today he's go jack will
serve on the board through the term may
and then he will go ahead and he will
leave he believes that
it's critical for the company to stand
on its own free of its founders
influence or direction
and then jack finishes with two
paragraphs he says i want you all to
know that this was my decision and i own
it it was a tough one for me of course i
love this service and company and all of
you so much i'm really sad yet really
happy there aren't many companies that
get to this level there aren't that many
founders that choose their company over
their own ego i know we'll prove this
was the right move we'll have all hands
tomorrow morning yada yada yada
but he then concludes with i'm tweeting
this email my one wish is for twitter
inc to be the most transparent company
in the world hi
mom
and so couple of takeaways immediately
one big news that jack dorsey is
stepping down two big news that it's
effective immediately three they're
going internal not external for a ceo
they're using their cto to become the
ceo pretty big deal there what i do
notice is that he is from india he
graduated from itt bombay and he is now
joining the ranks of people who run
everything from microsoft to google to
palo alto networks etc pretty damn cool
on top of that what we find is that jack
dorsey stepping down has a lot of
different implications one what will he
go do now well remember he still runs
square so obviously i think he'll only
double and triple down on square and
that by proxy will be a huge benefit
to bitcoin jack obviously has said
multiple times if he wasn't running
twitter he wasn't running square he
would be fully working on bitcoin i
would expect him to continue to move
more and more that way over time the
second thing is that a lot of people
have been giving jack dorsey a hard time
over the years they think that he hasn't
really built the company to what it
could be maybe maybe not but one thing i
do think that jack dorsey should get
immense credit for that he usually
doesn't is that jack dorsey has defended
free speech inside of twitter more so
than i think most other executives would
have if you think that the censorship on
twitter or other platforms is bad
imagine the censorship that would be
happening if jack wasn't there at
twitter my guess is that it would be
worse and so one of the things we're
gonna have to watch for here is is the
censorship is the d platforming gonna
get worse on twitter now that jack is
going ahead and stepping aside i don't
know but that's definitely something
that i'm gonna be watching so overall
jack dorsey stepping down from twitter i
think is going to be a net positive for
bitcoin it'll definitely be a net
positive for square and in some crazy
way twitter stock is up today which
means that people think it's a net
positive for twitter as well joe what
was your read when you saw that jack
dorsey was stepping down yeah a little
surprising i guess right he's he's
obviously done a very public and a good
job of running both square and twitter
so i think it's surprising from the
standpoint that he's actually doing it
but i think people internally uh that
look at twitter from a kind of an
operational perspective and a business
perspective kind of the stock and
everything like that they wouldn't
really be that surprised right it's
really tough to one to run one billion
dollar company it's really uh it's much
much harder i imagine to run two of them
so i think in the context of like taking
some things off his plate i'm sure
twitter will have uh kind of a different
leadership structure from that point of
view but it'll be interesting to see
what he does now right because i think
at some point people believe
is he going all in on bitcoin right is
he going to go work on a bunch of
different projects square related uh
that have to do with bitcoin he's he
released the white paper for the
decentralized exchange that square is
working on so that could be one thing
maybe he's just going to go on square
full time but i think people are
underestimating the impact that he will
eventually probably have on the bitcoin
ecosystem because as you mentioned he's
he's said this multiple multi multiple
times if he wasn't working on twitter
and square he'd be all in on bitcoin and
i think like you said this just moves
him one uh kind of step closer to that
eventual goal and it'll be interesting
to see kind of what projects and what
ambitions he goes after with square next
square's market cap 98 billion twitter's
market cap 37 around 37 billion dollars
he's built and led
almost 100 billion dollar company and
almost a 40 billion dollar company it's
absolutely insane he was what he was the
ceo of twitter from 06 to 08 that
stepped or got removed stepped down
whatever and then in 2015 came back um
and became the ceo again so it's crazy
to see i treat jack similar to like the
way i treat elon musk just don't bet
against him he's going to be successful
in anything he does uh and i can see him
going all in on bitcoin i can see him
going all in on philanthropy i can see
him going so many different avenues but
i think this is one step closer to him
to get to his end goal and i would not
be shocked if in either early next year
later next year he steps down from
uh square as well and kind of goes into
whatever side project he's working on or
whatever he wants he's gotten into
bitcoin mining recently so he's a ton of
avenues and i expect him to go into
cryptocurrency